Birmingham News reports Alabama's GOP
leadership is calling on Republican
Governor Robert Bentley to resign
immediately impeachment proceedings are
expected to begin today governor Bentley
has been caught up in a scandal since
last year when recordings revealed what
his wife claims was an affair with a top
aide in a report the State House
Judiciary Committee said the governor's
quote failure to cooperate with the
communities investigation is potentially
an independent grounds for his
impeachment Omar Villafranca is outside
the state capitol in Montgomery Alabama
Omar good morning good morning Governor
Robert Bentley ran as a law-and-order
Family Values candidate but last week
state Ethics Committee said he may have
violated campaign and ethics laws now
his wife has divorced him and his
political future is in question our
state doesn't need this anymore alabama
Governor Robert Bentley is battling
against his own state Republican
supermajority in order to keep his job
at issue whether Bentley broke the law
to cover up an alleged affair with a
former top staffer Rebecca Caldwell
Mason 74 year old Bentley defended
himself on Friday I do not plan to
resign I have done nothing illegal a 130
page report includes text messages
handed over to the house committees
special counsel by Alabama's former
first lady in one exchange Bentley
professes his love for Mason and Mason
responds bless our hearts and other
parts both Mason and Bentley have denied
an affair his constituents were quick to
react that's our hearts and other
products I think it's time for the guy
we're going to go home they have a seat
in 2014 Diane Bentley also secretly
recorded a conversation between her
husband and Mason
mrs. Bentley's then chief of staff
helped her record it in spring 2014 when
the governor became aware that staffer
said Bentley warned her to watch herself
and she did not know what she was
getting into I've talked to half a dozen
staffers who are named in the documents
who say it was just absolute fear and
intimidation John Archibald a columnist
with the Alabama Media Group says it
appears the governor went to great
lengths to keep the relationship secret
he's lost his family he has lost his
credibility he's lost everything he had
and he's about to lose his job the
report also states that Bentley misused
state resources when he ordered law
enforcement officials to break up with
Mason for him the hearing is expected to
last about a week Norah Wow Omar thank
you